bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france quel regard est ce que vous
portez sur la décision du président
tunisien de geler les activités du
parlement et de limoger le premier
ministre alors si la décision de
recourir à l'article 80 était plus ou
moins attendue parce que le président de
la république a souvent menacé en tout
cas a souvent indiqué qu'il allait
passer à l'étape suivante et qu'il
allait lancer ces missiles pour
reprendre ses termes
quelle est la dernière était un petit
peu enfin a pris tout le monde de court
mais on s'attendait à ce que un ski liés
à ce qu'il ya un clash ce que ça fait à
peu près un an qu'on vit dans une sorte
de guerre froide entre l'est ce qu'on
appelle les trois présidences donc le
président de la république que le
premier ministre chef du gouvernement et
le président du parlement qui est
lui-même le président du parti islamiste
donc l'affrontement était inévitable ça
a été on va dire doté par la crise du
colis de 19 en à peu près vingt mille
morts alors que l'année dernière il ya
eu un gouvernement qui a très très bien
su gérer la première crise qui l'a
contenu à une cinquantaine de morts et
surtout ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres
c'était il ya un mois alors que le pays
était complètement dans les compétences
et dans cette crise du coc vide
un des dirigeants du parti islamiste
avait déclaré qu' il fallait il fallait
mettre en oeuvre le avec le délai du 25
juillet d'où la date d'hier donc qui
correspond à la fête de la république de
mettre en oeuvre un fonds de
compensation des victimes de la
dictature qui sont essentiellement des
militants du parti islamiste
et donc ça crée une certaine colère
populaire les gens sont descendus dans
la rue hier un petit peu partout en
tunisie et le président en a profité
donc pour faire cette application de sa
très très particulière de l'article 81
ennahda le parti islamiste au pouvoir
évoque un coup d'état est ce que c'est
aussi votre sentiment
alors ce qu'on peut dire ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que l'article 81 tel qu'il a
été tel qu'il a été écrit ne permet pas
la dissolution du parlement et ne permet
pas donc de limoger le premier ministre
en tout cas de voter une motion de
censure contre lui mais le problème
c'est que pour dire le droit
il y à une cour constitutionnelle qui
aurait dû être mise en place selon cette
même constitution depuis au moins
l'année 2015 donc depuis maintenant six
ans
donc tout le monde a plus ou moins violé
la constitution c'est à dire que
l'interprétation du président de la
république de cet article 81
il y a clairement un dépassement
notamment dans le jeu fait le gel de des
activités du parlement
mais en même temps en face aussi on a
une coalition au pouvoir et notamment en
partie cela mist qui ne s'est pas gêné
pour aussi en tout cas s'arranger avec
certaines dispositions aussi bien
législatif que constitutionnel donc un
coup d'état il est trop tôt pour le dire
mais en tout cas l'article 86 devait
être appliquée dans le texte n'aurait
pas permis en tout cas le le gel des
activités du parlement sachant que
cingel d'un mois et que le parlement
aurait dû partir en vacances
parlementaires
donc si le gel le reste qu'à moi fait
les conséquences sur son travail ne vont
pas être non pas être extraordinaire le
seul problème qui vous allez payer la
crise sanitaire
est ce que ce sont aussi les
manifestations qui finalement ont poussé
kayes rsa aide à prendre ses décisions
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui soutenu par la
majorité de la population alors la
majorité c'est très difficile de le dire
il faut il faut qu'il y ait des des
sondages d'opinion et même les sondages
d'opinion en tunisie on a certains qui
sont pas très très sérieux mais si vous
voulez il ya un colère populaire qui
s'est exprimée notamment en début
d'année en janvier février
on a vu les gens des quartiers
populaires des centres et une colère
populaire face à ce que la tunisie enfin
l'état actuel de la tunisie
s'agissant de la crise de la crise
sanitaire et si vous voulez à chaque
fois qu'il ya un mouvement social qui
soit de d'ampleur une feinte de petite
ampleur ou d'ampleur moyenne
on voit souvent ce slogan de dissoudre
l'assemblée les gens demandent sans trop
me forcément connaître les les
les règles constitutionnelles demande à
ce que la l'assemblée soit dissoute donc
à side c'est qu'il y à une colère
populaire et et qu'il y a de ce qu'on a
vu en tout cas hier avec des scènes de
liesse
ce qu'il y ait en tout cas ils disposent
d'un soutien populaire aux relativement
important et qu'il majoritaire ou non
très difficile à dire mais en tout cas
il a pu s'offrir par exemple un bain de
foule à 2 heures du matin hier sur la
principale avenue de tunis l'avenue
bourguiba sans vraiment avoir de risque
pour sur son intégrité physique c'est à
dire qu'il ya une bonne partie du peuple
qui d'ailleurs d'obédiences politiques
très différentes de gauche de droite ou
des proches de l'ancien régime qui
veulent en finir avec le système mis en
place depuis depuis 2011 et donc le
président pour l'instant en tout cas
soutien de ceux d'un certain soutien
populaire qu'on n'arrive pas à
quantifier mais qui n'est pas du tout
négligeable un tout derniers mois assez
rapidement parce que le temps file vous
rappeler que les tensions notamment
entre présidence a aidé ennahda était
ville depuis plusieurs mois
rappelez-nous d'un mot pour quelle
raison est ce que la situation selon
vous peut s'arranger après ses récents
événements de la soirée notamment
alors je pense qu'on a atteint un point
de non-retour c'est à dire que là c'est
c'est très difficile maintenant c'est
chacun veut veut éliminer l'autre 1 ce
qui se passait comme hard demande à ses
militants d'aller protester et il va y
avoir des affrontements
la raison est très simple c'est que le
président du parlement
rachid ghannouchi s'est pris pour un
président de la république cette heure
il n'a pas été élu au suffrage universel
et il a mis son petit royaume autour de
lui intervenant sur des sujets qui
dépassent de loin ses prérogatives
notamment diplomatie et le président de
la république n'a juste pas supporter ça
c'est à dire ils n'arrêtent pas de dire
il faut qu'il y ait un état et donc une
personne qui guident cet état et ce
n'est pas possible d'avoir plusieurs
états dans un même état c'est ce qui
explique en tout cas les attaques qu'il
ya entre d'une part le président de la
république et d'autre part les
islamistes et le chef du parlement
merci beaucoup pour votre regard à thème
nafti essayiste je rappelle le titre de
votre dernier ouvrage de la révolution à
la restauration où va la tunisie c'est
aux éditions riveneuve